Hello again, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
I'll continue with our series on apoptosis.
So this is apoptosis 201, your next level course.
Last time we spoke about the difference between apoptosis and necrosis.
While apoptosis is a conservation or a recycling of all the genetic material, all the cellular
material and necrosis is basically the destruction of the cell, usually always pathological in the
necrosis.
Apoptosis can be pathological, but usually we think of it as a normal physiological response
where necrosis is not a normal physiological response per se, you can say it's a normal physiological
response in the event of an enemy attack, but it is destruction.
So why does apoptosis take place?
Why is this so important?
Well, there are normal physiological reasons for apoptosis.
It's normal in prudence.
So if anybody has ever had a garden or apple trees or fruit trees, if you don't prude
your garden, if you don't take care of it in that way, you're never going to have a good
crop of apples, you have to prude your garden, you have to pick the weeds, you have to take
care of it in order to grow a good crop.
So there is prudence that takes place from a neurological perspective, from a braid science
perspective.
So if you talk about your neurons get pruned, your neurons work on a use it or lose it
basis, so do your muscle cells.
If you don't use them, your body sees them as an important eduille, they will go through
apoptosis and be destroyed, they're not needed.
So you have to use your body in order to keep those cells.
Also, there are certain tissues that are hormone-dependent tissues, like endometrial tissues, women's
rest post lactation after they have a baby, there's an infiltration of new cells for making
a milk after the baby's done lactating, those cells go through apoptosis and are destroyed.
There's no need for them.
During a normal cycle, a woman's cycle goes through the endometrial tissue, goes through proliferation
and apoptosis.
So that's a normal process, a normal physiological process.
It's a way to get rid of those cells that are not needed anymore.
Cells that are necessary during development that aren't necessary after development go through
apoptosis.
So again, apoptosis is the way to recycle cells that aren't needed for that person's
well-being at this point, so the example would be specific T cells and auto antigen and bone
marrow cells go through apoptosis after they've served their purpose.
It really all cell lines, not every cell line, both your heart cells don't go through apoptosis,
but most your cell lines, once they reproduce, go through apoptosis.
It has been said that you have a brand new body, which isn't completely true, but for
the most part, you do have a brand new body and both cell lines, every about 12 to 24 weeks
as those cells reproduce another cell, and the mother cell, you could say, dies.
It goes through apoptosis, your body gets rid of it.
You just have too many cells in your body.
So we reproduce a new cell in order for it to do its job and the old cell dies.
That is normal apoptosis.
There are some pathological reasons that you go through apoptosis.
Any severe damage to the cell is going to cause the cell to die.
So this could be purposeful, and let's say if somebody goes through radiation or chemotherapy
in a purposeful attempt to kill a cell that is in rapid replication, that is a cancer cell,
but the problem is, is you damage any cell with radiation or chemotherapy, and you risk
it going through apoptosis.
That's just what happens.
That's the negative side of radiation and chemotherapy, is you're not just killing cancer
cells, you're killing every cell.
So not a good thing.
But there's other pathological reasons.
If there's thermal injury or if you go through a time where there's no oxygen to the cell,
any damage that's going to occur to the DNA, the endoplasmic reticulum, a viral infection
because remember viruses go inside the cell, and your immune system can recognize that there's
a virus inside the cell by a little receptor that comes out of the cell, right, and the
immune system can destroy that cell and basically gobble it up, and hence doing it kills the virus.
That's how your body will kill a virus.
Also, if a tumor suppressor gene is activated, you know, we talk a lot about the tumor suppressor
genes in our cancer series, and those are very important because those are the genes that
can become deactivated when somebody has cancer.
So a tumor suppressor gene is a gene that turns on the apoptosis cycle, and we'll talk more
about that in our later weeks here about apoptosis, but tumor suppressor genes turn on apoptosis.
When a person has cancer, the problem is tumor suppressor genes are turned off or disabled,
or a person has a genetic trait where they don't have certain tumor suppressor genes.
So when a tumor suppressor gene is activated or turned on, it activates apoptosis, excuse
me.
It is usually only turned on when there is rapid replication, so that is the body's defense
against cancer.
So you have cancer that's starting to grow in your body, tumor suppressor genes.
In this picture, the P53 gene, which is a very important tumor suppressor gene, stimulates
apoptosis, and helps kill that cancer.
So apoptosis is important.
There's pathological reasons for apoptosis, the person has cancer and the tumor suppressor
genes turned on, a viral infection, any stress to the cell, any damage to the cell, and there's
normal physiological reasons.
So that's the way your body cleans up itself and keeps your body healthy, and it sells that
once they reproduce, they go through apoptosis.
And that's what's broken, this cycle of apoptosis, that's the first thing that's broken in
order for a person to get cancer.
You can't have cancer unless apoptosis is not taking place.
We'll talk more about that in our next lecture.
There's really two pathways, we're going to get into it a little deeper, so stay tuned.
More information is in the book, so you can feel free to download the book and feel free to
go up into that left-hand corner, and go on our clinic website, our new clinic website
has a lot of information that we're adding all the time.
Dr. Kevin Connors, you have a great day.